[Music]
i'm assuming we are
so
any apologies
conflicts of interest
confirmation of minutes somebody
prepared to move 3.1 please move
councillor williams
secretary councillor blackie
i'll put it all those info please say
aye
against carrie
any matters arising from the minutes
you know
i have no deputations we go on to
reports 5.1
who's running there
who's running kelly
kelly's going to lead away with that
this report is on the
february 2022 flood event um i'd first
of all like to begin by
introducing emil clopper from becca
he is on the call he is one of two
consultants we have engaged to assist us
with our um
flood work
so he is the flood team
lead
uh we also have jack boyd from ws uh
sorry from stantec assisting us as well
so the purpose of this report is to give
an update on the current status of the
further work we're doing in response to
not only the february event but also
picking up on the
uh may 2021 and december
2021 event as well
um
there is about 600 service requests that
we've been working through
and they have been triaged and grouped
and you'll see that we have got
roughly about 60 further investigations
that we are currently working our way
through
so
obviously that's quite a large amount of
work and we're expecting that's going to
take a number of months two or three
months for us to work through
but we're currently getting a more
definitive program together
in terms of communications everyone that
has launched the service requests has
had an initial response
and we intend
directly following up with people to
let them know the outcome of the further
investigation work
we are also putting out some general
communications so that's in the form of
updating our web page so currently that
is out of date but we are working
through a draft to update that at the
moment
um and that will cover
information on the most recent event as
well as the
60 odd investigations that we're
progressing through
um we're also
underway with doing targeted
uh consultation to the kaiapoi residents
a lot of the service requests we got for
kayak were related to
uh issues that will be addressed as part
of the shovel ready project so that is
going to get integrated with
communications
for the shop already works and then we
plan to do a more targeted
um
flyer potentially as part of a local
newsletter to the waikuku beach
residence
it's fair to say that
with the amount of rainfall that we've
had
we've got saturated catchments in the
district and also groundwater levels are
very high at the moment um particularly
in the coastal area
um and our drainage team is experiencing
quite a number of uh service requests at
the moment um in the report i think i
signaled that we had about 1400 service
requests
in the last um
year
uh in just over the two weeks that we
have had since this report was written
that has now increased to about 1530 so
that's almost
double what we get in a typical 12 month
period
so that just signals
the quantum of work that we're trying to
work through at the moment
in terms of maintenance work this isn't
covered in the report but i just thought
i'd give you a quick update because i
know there has been some concerns about
um maintenance recently particularly in
the kaiapoi area
so uh bellwood dream has been fully
cleared out
uh the punt station we've done the
initial investigation work
um and that has identified that some
remedial works will need to be done but
there's further investigation of the
pumps that we need to do there
dudley drain has been cleaned out from
ahoka road through down to hilton street
and there's still a section to do
between hilton and raven key
and sunday school drain along the
railway line has been cleaned out
uh you'll note in section 4.7 of the
report the list of nearly 60 drainage
investigations um
that we are proceeding with um and we've
at today we've just highlighted which
ones are underway
but in future reports we hope to give
you more of a program of when we'll be
working through those
the key thing with that list is just to
make sure we've captured everything and
that nothing is missing
i'm happy to take any general comments
but if there are specific issues
relating to particular
properties it's probably best to address
those separately
uh so like i've signaled this is a first
of
subsequent reports to come back to this
committee um to keep you informed of
progress as we work through all of these
investigations
um just a further point to note that
if any capital works comes out of these
investigations um
we will be
addressing those as part of a staff
submission to the
2223 annual plan
so happy to take any questions
thanks kelly so i've got dan paul and
then neville dan
thanks kelly very good report thank you
for that um
the comms pieces that you're talking
about they're flyers and material just
wondering if you could make sure that
the drafts are sent by our elected
members to see before they go out to see
that they are addressing the points that
we're aware of in those communities
sure we can do that um we're also
working with our comms team on those as
well
thank you
chancellor williams
yeah hi kelly um i'm just a wee bit
concerned about um the ability of our
contractors to um have enough um
men on the ground for doing it do we
need to bring in extra contractors to um
get some of these problems um
particularly the maintenance ones that
have been outstanding for
quite a number of um
time now so
is it time to bring in some extra help
to help our existing contractors
uh you we would yes we will definitely
be looking at that um
and it's fair to say that there is a
backlog of maintenance work and um also
some of our contractors are struggling
with resources from a covert perspective
as well
um i know that jared has been in contact
with the counterpart at court
and um they have made um
prioritize uh work such that we're
getting back on top of the maintenance
program here
um
but if necessary if
they are still struggling to keep up
then we would look at external resources
beyond our maintenance contractor to get
that work done
okay
so council reckons you put your hand
down you you happy camper
thanks mr chair i'll just it was the run
reviews uh news so i just wondered um
how far along that investigation is
yes so just generally talking about that
we have had some
cctv work undertaken both on-site and
off-site there
um
it hasn't identified any obvious
blockages but it has identified a number
of different things that we are
following up on
um both in terms of on-site
um
that it appears that the um
that there might be some on-site works
that we can do regarding venting to
improve improve the situation
and secondly um
looking at our system downstream there's
evidence of surcharge occurring um that
we haven't fully got our heads around at
the moment
so um further investigations are ongoing
there uh we were um monitoring the
recent rainfall event that we've had
overnight there was a little bit of a
response in that catchment but um
nothing obvious
uh or nothing major rather the other
thing that we're doing is deploying uh
level sensors into that catchment so we
can actually see
um to what extent the system is
surcharging during future rainfall
events
so potentially the way forward there
depending on those the outcome of that
investigation might actually be a
combination of doing improvements both
within our articulation in the street as
well as upgrades to the onslaught
reticulation at brandon news
councillor stewart followed by
councillor barney
thank you
i looked for the web page the other
night and couldn't find anything you
indicate that you're updating it is
there actually any
any web page anywhere that um the public
can go to at the moment because i
couldn't it's not on the home page where
where is it
uh yeah it is a little bit difficult to
navigate to so that will be one thing
that we address with um the comms people
in terms of making it more obvious
to get to it at the moment you need to
go to water services
storm water
and then it's under the drainage works
link
okay well that would be nice too i mean
can even that go
go on um the home page or somewhere
where
um it makes it easier i mean i would
have wouldn't have found it that in a
million years
but um yeah looking forward to
actually seeing um
communications
ramp up on all this thank you
thank you councilor barnett
yes thank you very much kelly um
probably more of a question for jared
jared if he's there um
but
there was a lot of other work that was
all to do with signs and uh flooding
preparation for next time and i noticed
there's been the odd thing has been done
but have we seen an overall report of
the roading and drainage
actual the progress together because
rather than doing it department by
department because it's kind of hard to
know who to ask
um yeah that's actually a really good
question so there are a number of things
we've done in terms of um there's been
some requests for permanent you know
examples of permanent signs those sorts
of things which we're um
initiating
we do have uh we do actually have a need
for um bringing
a report relating to roading to the
committee we've been engaging with waka
katahi about co-funding
and you know and those are ongoing so
the most recent uh being the bridge
collapse in um
mill road so we uh so yes that's so we
should uh bring another report whether
we bring it as a roading report and a
separate drainage report or we include
it in the next
update um
we'll we'll present it um whichever is
going to work
but uh yeah you're right we should we
should be actually reporting to you on
the roading issues as well rather than
just drainage
council blocky
thank you kelly uh we did that tour in
in um after february in kayak we were
several of us with you um and we and we
looked at those drills that hadn't been
lifted for two years etc etc you were
going to go to cycon court and come back
to us because we were we were talking
about a brief actual breach of the
contract there in that i think you said
those things uh meant to be routinely
inspected as it was at 12 weekly
something like that and they haven't
been for literally years
did you um
a cost just that's the right word called
on
i mean apart from the covert short as a
manpower i get that but did you actually
talk to them about not fulfilling the
contract as it is written and what was
their response to that
uh so we have had a discussion
internally with that and that was part
of jared's discussion with cord as well
they had feedback to us that they uh um
they want to be proactive in that space
to to address it and to
uh the areas that were pointed out um
during that tour to use those as um
indicators of you know where areas are
not being addressed so um cord gave a
a very positive response to that as i
understand it jared
yes look i've taken that um up at a
senior level uh with cord as part of our
regular um schedule of meetings
and they've certainly uh they've
definitely not only demonstrated a
willingness but um have agreed to a
program
of um inspections and maintenance uh
that we're that are that's required so
and we're so we're definitely working
through that with our
um road maintenance
contractor right now
thanks for that
i can't see any more questions we have a
recommendation in front of us somebody
prepared to move
move councillor williams
seconded
council blacky councillor
williams any comment
you muted there paul
sorry
yeah it's just um straight forward i
think it's something we need to
start going with haste because um
nothing worse than water getting near um
properties and everything and um we are
quite uh behind in some of our
maintenance so um
it's good to get things moving
thank you
councillor blecky yeah no nothing to add
thanks kelly good report
councillor stewart
uh thank you another question actually
um
of the drainage request that you've
listed here in the report
um
how many are not in a
drainage uh rating area is it just those
nine in the district drainage
list or are there more
um
i'm not sure off the top of my head emil
might have that more information at his
fingertips i'm not sure
um
but
i think that there's probably an
indication of um
you know the fact that we've got 9 out
of 59
investigations is probably about um an
indication of how many direct service
requests we would have had from outside
of drainage rating areas emil i'm not
sure if you can add anything further to
that
yeah no i agree i'm not 100 sure how
many i have it somewhere and uh and one
of my spreadsheets and i can give it to
you um but not i
i don't have it in front of me yet we
can follow up with the email
you know if you could um just do that
analysis and send it out to all of us
just for information that would be
appreciated thank you
we'll do
uh any reply counselor williams
no i'll put it all those in favor thumbs
up
passed
look at those gates
get carried
um brings us through to
5.2
colin i think you're leading this i
think
oh yes that's right thank you and good
afternoon um so this report is
um to gain the utilization voting
committee's endorsement of proposed
submissions on the drinking water
standards so
one of tomato ottawa's first jobs after
they became the new drinking water
regulator
was to review the drinking water
standards and revise them and which has
meant basically a complete overhaul of
the old standard so rather than revising
them that's it's a whole new set of
standards and rules
um
we've prepared submissions on five of
their different consultation documents
and also a cover letter um
as
as you'll be aware there's we're
um
i've got an amended recommendation which
i'll share at the end as well just um
and talk through that a little bit more
but i'll just go through
a couple of key points briefly and then
get to the the immediate recommendation
after that so
um yeah as i said there's five
consultation documents so there's quite
a lot of content there
um
and i definitely won't go through it all
but a couple of key points that i'd made
were um
one of the documents was about the
aesthetic values these have a greater
waiting under the water services act
where suppliers are expected to take all
predictable steps to meet them whereas
in the old under the health act they
were just guideline values and there's
no obligation to meet them so that
creates a greater level of significance
which i think hadn't been
thought through fully with some
aesthetic parameters in there
such as a minimum ph value and a minimum
chlorine level
actually not having any acidic meaning
as far as i could see no one can taste
water with a low ph
and no one complains if they can't taste
chlorine strong enough in their water so
i think those particular ones were
misplaced in the aesthetic
section so i suggested they be removed
the most significant document is the
quality assurance rules which is all the
documentation around what suppliers need
to do to demonstrate
compliance
in general there's a lot more reporting
a lot more monitoring a lot more
sampling
and there are requirements in water
services act
or a theme in the act anyway that
obligations for suppliers be
proportionate to scale
in one area in particular where i felt
that wasn't the case was with some of
the distribution system monitoring
um where under the current standards
suppliers need to take a monthly e coli
sample
for very small suppliers of 50 people
right up to 20 000 people and they now
require a daily checks of
chlorine and ph levels so
with that
first going from monthly to daily is a
big change and also having the same
requirements from 50 people up to 20 000
didn't seem to be taking into account
they're proportionate to scale
requirement
um
so i made that one of my key points is
just to ensure they actually are
proportionate to scale um rather than in
some cases um having quite onerous
requirements right down to the very
smallest suppliers um
and then i think the most significant
point i that i had made
um
was around the transition time frames
there's as i said earlier there's a lot
of new obligations with sampling um
reporting and also more treatment
requirements so suppliers that didn't
used to need treatment will now need
treatment
and
despite the
required changes being so significant
the signal time frame to comply is
basically
that we expect to get confirmation on
what the final standards are sometime in
may
possibly mid to late may and then be
expected to comply from the first of
july so
while we've been waiting
you know close to six years to see what
these standards are post have like north
to to have only six weeks then come up
to meet them
as as a very short turnaround um
and that point has been made already in
the draft submission
um but the recommendation i'll just
share now that i'm proposing
is really just to strengthen some of
that so
uh just let me get familiar with zoom
which i don't usually use
this one looks like a kit
so
hopefully you can all see that now
um
colin can you zoom in a bit please
so the and black is the recommendations
on in the report that was on the agenda
and then read as the proposed additional
word so what
i'm suggesting is that there will be
final amendments made to these
submissions
in particular to reinforce the
transitional issues um
associated with the standards and
particularly with regard to coronation
at the approval of the chief executive
and mayor taking into account feedback
received from councillors so
um
we'll have a workshop later on the
general um
you know
chlorine exemption process and the new
standards and how those
line up um and that
will be an opportunity to get any really
detailed feedback but um yeah we felt
like they they this
will be new information coming to light
about exactly how the transition will
work that
we think we haven't fully covered in the
submission although we've touched on
transition to some extent so that was
the proposed amendment
um
so that and that's also um
essentially what i wanted to say and
talking to this so i'm happy to take any
questions
um i'll stop sharing this but i can do
it again if people want to
look at it
so councillor stuart is your hand still
up from the previous or do you have a
new question no i've got a new question
thank you um i apologize for not ever
actually going into all those
separate submissions that you've
done i couldn't see how to do that but
however
my question is maximum allowable values
for
iron manganese arsenic nitrate is any
material change um to those levels in
this new standards proposed
no not not material in general the
standards are based
or the maximum acceptable values are
based on world health organization
values
by and large which was the case with the
old standard so there's been no
significant change
with any of those parameters um
yeah i thought nitrate had gone down as
far as the world health organization
to about around about 10
milligrams
uh there has there is some across the
board and this was actually the case
with the ministry of health standards as
well as the tomato ottawa ones the
ministry of health i think their
standards are based on an average adult
weight of 60 kilograms and then in new
zealand that's amended to 70 kilograms
so some of the world health organization
values
increase for new zealand by whatever
that percentage difference is so that
might be why we're 11.3 for nitrate and
not
but that was that's not a change with
these standards versus the old that's um
that's always been the case
yeah so and that all remains
yes
thank you
council blackie
thank you um kelly the just confirmation
please the
the small suppliers i'm thinking farms
here with farm cottages am i correct in
thinking that uh one cottage um apart
from the main house is okay and more
than one they'll be rated as a supplier
is that correct
yeah that that is correct so these um
that was already set basically by the
water services act they are suppliers
but these standards are what set out
what those suppliers then have to do to
prove compliance and
that was another point that i've made in
the and the proposed submissions that um
again i didn't feel like
the
i think they're headed in the right
direction and that they have what
they've called acceptable solutions so
basically rather than
having a really comprehensive set of
standards for even the tiniest little
supplier they've basically said if you
build a successful solution and monitor
in this way then you'll comply
so i think the philosophy is good to get
just almost like an off-the-shelf
treatment system for cartridge filtering
uv
and a small supplier will comply but
again they haven't really
taken into account the proportionate to
scale thing as much as they could so
some of those acceptable solutions for
either spring or bore water or rural
agricultural supplies they have the same
requirements from like one or i guess
two houses right up to 500 people
whereas um some of the other rules on
demand supplies they have a less than 50
category and then a 50 to 500 category
so i'm saying
that they should have a less than 50
category for all those ones because
they're probably going to get tens of
thousands of two house supplies and not
that many kind of 400 person
suppliers so they
the rules have been tailored towards the
larger end of the scale not the smaller
end
yeah even with the what i've submitted i
think it is still going to be a big step
up for those small suppliers but um
yeah it's
i guess it's finding that balance
okay so we have an amended
recommendation as a member prepared to
move moved council williams
seconded
some off second
councillor williams
yet no thank you colin good report and i
think we need to um
carry on with their good work on our
waters thank you
i've got nothing to add any other
members
no reply i'll put it all those in favor
please say aye
thumbs up
against
carried moves on to item sticks which is
uh correspondence i have none
reports referred so there's one
meter for information 8.1
somebody prepared to move that we
receive 8.1
move councillor blackie seconded
me
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
against
carrie
go into quick round of portfolio
updates roading councillor williams
yeah um not a great deal on roading at
the moment i went on a um we trip
yesterday um uh inspecting some of their
uh gravel roads and um
some of them have been washed out a wee
bit by a lot of flood waters and um
the heavy rain we've had um so
we do need to look at um
remedying a few of the um the problems
there um
so that's really a about on the the
roading side of things at this stage
thank you very much drainage in stock
water council stuart
thank you um just looking forward to a
briefing that
is in the works on uh
drainage rating
uh as you know we have a bit of a
mishmash across the district with urban
and some rural and here we have and a
district-wide
flood protection drainage rate
and and we also have ecan now proposing
a new region-wide
rate i'd like to get my head around
um
exactly what all these different rates
are going to deliver and we have a
briefing
i understand coming to us on that
uh and i'm waiting to see the draft on
the new stock water by-law
communications package
thank you
thank you um utilities councilor
williams
hi yes
um waste water constructions works on
the sea uh central rangera sewer stage
five and wooden road rising main
projects progressing well
um
i see the um the one from logan lee is
um connected on the um hd side of it and
that's progressing um
well as well um water supply um
[Music]
we're continuing with the flushing and
testing on the um
the wood-end copper schemes following a
high collar from detection um
so um that's happening um we've had a
couple of burst pipes on the um church
street made this and um so that's being
investigated um the reasons why that's
um
been happening at the moment um
that's really
the backflow prevention policy is still
ongoing and um
yeah and it's all happening so that's
about it on the water okay
thank you very much solid waste which is
me
you will have seen that i sent out an
email half an hour before the the
meeting that was in the interest of time
and hopefully that can be included in
the minutes however one thing that
didn't include was an email i got from
kitty yesterday
she wants to reintroduce audits
i had a
while it's operational it's also a
political aspect
i raised the health and safety uh
concern that i had um she assures me
that that
is being mitigated
and that they'll be fully gowned and be
using a stick as opposed to physically
going into the buns
if any members have an issue with regard
to those audits being recommenced if you
could send me an email be much
appreciated um so that's it from me we
go to transport the mayor please
uh thanks
mr chia just just briefly uh hit a
meeting uh with the nzta and a concerned
resident regarding mohawk's road it was
really to try and get an understanding
in alignment of what the nzta are
proposing
uh
a long line side road in the works that
we need to be considering this resident
was concerned with uh
under the level of accidents that
happened there so that was a good
engagement and obviously that's
something we'll be discussing further
with staff and due course but to
understand
nzta's direction there which they have
an entirely unentirely clear about at
this point was useful to um to gain an
understanding of uh the other is we've
got a meeting with the minister
chief executives joining that with the
greater christchurch partnership as the
minister of transport on the 4th of
april it's really to talk about
investment in the greater christchurch
partnership area
and that's been
driven by
notices of motion and christian city
council and salman and we we've
supported that conversation and said
that it should be at a greater
christchurch level and pleased that they
have
decided to do that and it includes all
the greater christchurch partnership so
it's on the 4th of april
thank you very much
so we go on to item 10 questions i have
none i have no urgent general business
so i'll move from the chair that we go
into
public excluded somebody prepared the
second
yep councilor williams thank you and
we'll wait to be disconnected i guess
[Music]
you